près de 20 millions de cas détectés pas
loin de trois cent quarante mille morts
enregistrés depuis le début de la
pandémie
ce triste bilan fait des états unis le
pays le plus durement touché par le cos
vite 19 dans le monde
avec les nombreux déplacements liés à 5
giving et aux fêtes de fin d'année les
chiffres n'ont fait que s'aggraver
et pour ne rien arranger un premier cas
d'une variante britannique du virus
nettement plus contagieux a été détectée
ce mardi dans l'état du colorado
le gouverneur police et les responsables
sanitaires de l'état ont annoncé avoir
détecté un premier cas au colorado du
variant b1 1,7 du coc vie 19 le même
variant découvert au royaume uni
l'individu est un homme d'une vingtaine
d'années qui est actuellement à l'
isolement dans le comté d'el berthe et
n'a pas d'antécédents de voyage des
nouvelles très inquiétante d'autant que
l'objectif affiché par donald trump de
vacciner 20 millions d'américains d'ici
la fin de l'année ne sera pas atteint
une situation dénoncée par joe biden qui
regrette ce retard cuite dans le plan de
vaccination
l'effort de distribution et
d'administration du vaccin ne
connaissent pas comme il le devrait
il ya quelques semaines l'administration
de repas suggéré que 20 millions
d'américains pourraient être vaccinées
d'ici la fin décembre quelques jours en
décembre et nous n'en avons vacciné que
quelques millions jusqu'à présent
si le programme de vaccination continue
d'avancer à ce rythme là il faudra des
années et non des mois pour vacciner
tous les américains
en attendant de déballer ses cartons la
maison blanche l'administration maiden
encourage plus que jamais les américains
à se faire vacciner pour enrayer une
épidémie hors de contrôle
ce mardi la vice présidente élue kamala
harris s'est à son tour fait inoculé le
remède
je viens d'être vaccinés comme je le dis
souvent il ya une grande différence
entre le vaccin et les vaccinations
je veux encourager tout le monde à se
faire vacciner c'est relativement
indolore cela va très vite c'est sans
danger
joe biden a d'ores et déjà prévenu s'il
espère des progrès à l'horizon du mois
de mars
les prochaines semaines seront
certainement les plus difficiles depuis
le début de la pandémie